what's up everybody
so Avengers infinity war has been on DVD
for about a week now and the DVD has so
many bonus features and so much new
information from directors commentaries
etc I've done some videos and some of
the things we've received and it's just
been really awesome and if you haven't
seen the movie yet or you don't own your
own copy yet be sure to enter the
giveaway I'm doing all you have to do to
be entered is subscribe to this channel
like this video and comment below with
your favorite superhero so a lot has
come out with the DVD but something that
was actually released a few days ago
that wasn't a part of the DVD is new
concept art for the movie that we
received and they're really awesome a
lot of cool photos here that just give
us a little bit of a different look at
some of the scenes in the movie and they
also do give us a better look at some of
the designs of the characters the way
that the creators saw them so let's
start with this awesome photo of Thor I
love this I think it's an amazing photo
looks like it's right when Thor got
Stormbreaker there's lightning going
around all over the place Lightning
going through him his eyes are white and
if you take a look at his arm you can
see that his armor is actually starting
to form back on him which is something
that we actually didn't see in the movie
we didn't see Thor grab his hammer for
the first time because he was
unconscious so this is a super cool
photo and it kind of gives you a better
idea of what it would have been like if
we actually saw him grab the hammer this
next photo is of Iron Man holding on to
spider-man or Peter Parker this was
actually a scene that was supposed to
take place in Avengers infinity war but
they reshot it in this scene when Peter
Parker falls Tony actually grabs him and
of course what we saw in Avengers
infinity war was the iron spider soup
going on its own and morphing around
spider-man saving him in the process
this next photo is of spider-man and the
iron spider suit this is a super cool
photo of this suit it looks like a shiny
brand-new car and according to Peter
Parker smells like one too super
to see a still of the iron spider suit
to see the design the colors and the
effort that went into it this next photo
is of Drax and Thanos and although the
fight between Drax and Thanos on Titan
was very brief I think it definitely
demonstrated that Drax is just no match
for Thanos you can see here by the
expression on Drax's face and thanasis
face Drax is just nothing compared to
fan oohs this next one is of Bucky who
an Avengers infinity war dropped the
title of being the Winter Soldier and
became the white wolf you get a really
good close-up look of his new vibranium
arm here and as you can see no star on
it next one is awesome as well
it's got Thor with Stormbreaker in his
arm and his new armor a lot of black
going on here normally his arm armor is
kind of more silver but it's a lot of
black and I'm wondering if they did this
because black is the color morning and
he lost a lot of people when Thanos
attacked a ship also worth mentioning is
that he is holding Stormbreaker
like a hammer not like an axe as you can
see the hammer head is actually facing
down and the axis facing up but we all
know that at the end it was the axe that
went right into Thinnes chest this next
photo is really awesome because it's
always really cool to see Doctor Strange
uses magic but as you can see in this
photo his magic is having just zero
effect on Thanos you have to keep in
mind just how strong Santos is without
the stones but give him the stones and
he's unstoppable doesn't matter how
strong you are these next few photos
right here are of Iron Man's nanotech
suit the really cool thing I liked about
the nanotech suit is how slick and sleek
it is the nanomachines form right to his
body so as you can see the suit takes on
the shape of his body it's not a clunky
huge piece of machine that Tony wears
his armor it's actually formed to his
body so in a way he actually kind of
becomes more one with his suit this
photo is of curva slave on the left and
one of Thanos has outriders on the right
I really like the design for Corvus
glaive it's
comic-book accurate even though he
didn't really get that much screen time
I thought we would see the children of
Thanos a little bit more but I certainly
understand when you have so many
characters in a story it's really hard
to give them a lot of screen time
individually and the outriders were
super cool they definitely gave us a
great battle in Wakanda
these next two photos are of doctor
strains and Wang and in the first photo
it shows dr. strange getting banner out
of the hole that he made when he fell
into the sanctum sanctorum as the Hulk
something we didn't see on screen so
it's nice to know how banner got out of
there and the next one is the fight
between doctor strains and ebony MA
apparently this was supposed to get a
little bit more film time than it did
again you have so many characters that
you have to fit into two and a half
hours I understand why this was a really
cool scene though and I would have loved
to have seen just a little bit more of
it
and this last amazing shot right here is
of the mad Titan Thanos there he stands
in all of his power at his home planet
of Titan but if you look closely at the
Infinity Gauntlet you can tell a slight
difference the Infinity stones are not
in the same place that they were in in
the movie I'm not sure if this means
that they originally planned on Thanos
getting the stones in a different order
or if the artists just randomly threw
the stones into the Infinity Gauntlet
when they designed this either way still
an awesome photo so that does it for all
the new Avengers infinity war concept
art that was released let me know what
you all think of this new concept art in
the comments below and another reminder
about our giveaway all you have to do to
enter to win a free blu-ray copy of
Avengers infinity war is subscribe to
this channel like this video and comment
below with your favorite superhero thank
you so much for watching woof woof
[Music]
you